So now we can handle expressions like
(2 + 3) or (x + 1)
but if you think about most of the Python programs you've written,
they've got quite a bit more going on--
things like "if" statements or assignment statements
that influence the state or change which parts of the program are executed.
Formally, we say that statements or program parts,
like "if" or "while" or "return"
change the flow of control, and a potential
reasonable analogy for control flow is a river.
Here, I've written a relatively simple bit of Python code.
But we could sort of trace through it,
noting which lines get visited.
We're definitely going to visit: x = 1.
We'll take a look at this "if"
because (x) is 1, it's less than 5
so we're going to curve in here and evaluate this "print".
But then we're going to kind of skip over
this whole "else" branch
and rejoin things here--so you've got this flow
that sometimes branches, seems to fork,
rejoins at the end--Control Flow.
Which part of the program do we execute?
If I'm to keep my finger on the line
that we're currently worried about, how does my finger move around?
We're going to need to handle this sort of things
if we're building an interpreter for JavaScript and HTML.
So things like "if", "while", and "return"
change the flow of control.
These things are called "statements"
to distinguish them from "expressions".
Expressions are typically a bit simpler.
They're more like noun phrases in a natural language.
A statement is more like an entire sentence.
It's going to contain a verb as well or some instruction,
like change the value of (x)
or jump over here.
Statements often contain expressions
but not the other way around.
And you can think of this as being a bit of a hierarchy.
This whole thing is a statement.
The usual abbreviation for a statement is "stmt".
But just this little part down here is an expression--
just like a whole sentence may contain one or two nouns.
So let's say we have an environment that maps
the variable, (x), to the value, 2--
and now I've written a JavaScript program below it
that contains an if-then-else statement--it should remind you a lot of Python.
If (x < 5), the variable, (y), is going to be assigned to "don";
otherwise, the variable, (y), is going to be assigned "quixote".
In our environment, where (x) is 2,
(x < 5) will be evaluated to True.
So the flow of control will visit here
and here, but will skip these two and rejoin us down here at the bottom.
And hopefully, at the end of the day, we'll have a new environment
where (x) maps to 2, and the variable (y) maps to "don".
"Don Quixote" is a classic novel,
written by Miguel de Cervantes around 1605.
We get a number of expressions from it, like
"Tilting at windmills" , in English;
the protagonist believes a windmill to be a mortal foe,
perhaps a dragon, and he charges up but gets knocked down
by the whirling arms each time.
These days, "tilting at windmills" means
trying something over and over again,
even though you know you're never going to succeed--an impossible task.